McLaren is an interesting car you know
they were known for their formula 1 yes
and only recently have they begun
selling production cars again they did
one in the 90s and so busy they're
trying to take on car makers like
Ferrari and Lamborghini and they came
out the car called the 12c a couple
years ago and it fell a little flat I
drove the car and I think it's actually
one of the best cars I've driven ever as
a sports car but isn't as sexy as a
Ferrari it didn't sound as good as a
Ferrari and I think some of the drivers
were disappointed so now they're
introducing the 650s which is sort of
like it's a shift in strategy
seventy-five percent in same car as the
12c costs about 20 grand more or more
and looks much cooler what does the
total price for something like this a
20,000 more than what well let's see the
converts at 265 all right tous again man
I drove a convertible which came to
about 350 350 so this is chilly you know
I'm just gonna say no this is clearly
not your first or your second carts more
like this is yeah this are you 43 fifth
card now you're less for a hardcore a
very fast sports car you know somebody
who bought the droid 4 or 5 8 would be
cross shopping with this car for
instance cross shopping with the Ferrari
458 the bluff I babe this is how my
family do they expect to sell any idea
they sold 3512 seized over since 2012
model which actually isn't that bad in
the supercar world but I think they
wanted a bigger hit I think they were a
little disappointed with with the
reaction from actual buyers I'm you know
Ferrari it keeps their residual values
so high and really right now you could
go buy a 12c for a lot cheaper than the
original so I actually think go look for
12 0